good morning Johnny it's Wednesday
August first it's Wednesday which means
that I have a singsong first I would
like to say happy birthday to Harry
Potter
yesterday it turns out that Harry Potter
and I are the same age so we would have
been at school at the same time but I
don't think that we would have been in
the same house someone asked and I think
I probably would have been a ravenclaw
but I would like to think that I would
have stayed to the end I wrote a lot of
this song while I was laying in bed it
took off the morning and I couldn't
sleep for two reasons one was because I
had had too much caffeine but the other
reason is what this song is about my
snap open it's two o'clock I rip up my
shirt my pants my socks something's
wrong but I don't know what but then I
finally realize their sweat trickling
down my thighs in a fire between the
mattress and my buddy
it's too hard
it's too hot I'm gonna fall off of my
chair if I have another ice-cold beer I
forgot how much it sucks to sweat in bed
I don't want to drink your iced tea I
want to take a bath in it instead it's
too hot
laying on the floor with my clothes off
some boxer shorts in a washcloth are the
only things I'll let touch my skin today
spraying myself and upside down here can
pick it out with the window fan hoping
the mailman does it look in today it's
too hot it's too hot in this town my
will to live is melting and that's
what's got me down it's too hot and my
state is on fire on an Indo thermic
organism and that's why I perspire when
it's too hot
the United Nations says he lovin
people lie about CG
the burning started once 11001 but it's
not gonna get me here
no it's not gonna get me
sweating in my basement all alone
watching hotness prevails poco pinecone
sympathize with my favorite YouTube star
how could anyone be so deranged to not
believe in climate change when it's 102
in Montana in the dark it's too hard and
I'm doing a funny dance cuz I win got
some ice cubes and I put them in my
pants it's too hot it's too hot in here
I'm probably gonna pass out
but please pass my beer it's too hot
so in myself with an upside air can I
can love with that window fair yes I
actually poured the iced on my pants
oh there's actually and this is proof a
piece of ice in my pocket I just found
and has been sitting there while I
edited this video John
I'll see you tomorrow